- I think in fourth grade
you learn about the Civil War
which is very important but you also learn
who your enemies are.
You learn a lot in the fourth grade.
You know what I mean?
(light music)
- [Voiceover] What's
the difference between
arteries and veins?
- Arteries.
Okay, veins, alright, are these things.
- A vein is like,
well, I know what vein is
but it's a less important,
it's like the stump of
the tree is the artery
and then the branches are the veins
so the artery is the important part.
- Veins is where you blood runs
and then arteries are,
is it inside the veins, the arteries?
- Okay, I think I got it.
Okay, I got it.
An artery brings blood to the heart
and veins take it away?
- [Voiceover] Who came up
with the Three Laws of Motion?
- That would be.
- The Three Laws of Motion.
- Shit.
Einstein?
What did Darwin do again?
Did they work together?
Like Einstein and Dar,
who should I go with?
- Newton.
- Newton?
- Isaac Newton?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Yes?
Oh my God, yeah, awesome.
God, okay, I feel good about life now.
When was the American Revolutionary War?
- I don't know.
- I remember it like it was yesterday.
1842.
- 1812?
- Is that against England?
- Maybe 1930s.
Earlier than 1930s.
1830s?
1850s.
- 1778.
No no no.
1785 to 1801.
- 1776 to 1783.
We can dance all day.
Really?
I would say that's bullshit.
Really, 1775?
Solve 123 divided by five.
- I don't remember how to
do long division at all.
- Five goes under 12.
Divided by five.
I remember it being like this.
- So you can go five times
two and it's 10.
- Five goes into 100 20 times
or yeah, 20 times.
- This doesn't mean anything.
This is just for my brain.
(light music)
- Then you got this
pesky little three here.
- I don't know what we do with this part
but we're 24.3 maybe.
- And then five doesn't go
into three so I have no idea.
I'm just going to do that.
24.2
I made it up.
- And your answer is 24.6.
- Look at that, you don't even need
to know long division.
It's all bullshit.
You just multiply everything.
(light music)